all right as a millions of people shift
from working from home the American
Academy of Pediatrics is offering advice
to stressed-out parents it's telling
them to practice self-care reach out to
others and watch out for signs of
increased stress in children the
Association warns that this can lead to
more frustration for the entire family
psychologist madeline levine is the
author of ready or not preparing our
kids to thrive in an uncertain and
rapidly changing world she joins us from
San Francisco good morning and welcome
thank you thank you how do we prepare
our kids for something like this you
know we've never had something quite
like this so it's no wonder that that
people are feeling at odds in terms of
figuring out what to do with their kids
I think there are some basic things that
are really important with children what
depending on their age you know people
talk about children as if they're all
the same but they're not they every
family's different and children think
very differently at different ages so
the way you talk to a five-year-old is
not how you talk to an 11 year old is
not how you talk to a 15 year old and I
think people need to keep that in mind
so let's take it in order then with that
younger bracket of kids a 5 year olds I
mean how do you how do you talk about a
virus and and a potentially deadly virus
with people that young I think you don't
frankly I think less is more with young
children I think for the most part kids
get their sense of what's going on not
so much from your words young kids but
from your body language and your tones
so they're going to be vaguely curious
their answers you know why are we home
we're home to keep everyone safe why are
we not seeing grandma we'll see grandma
soon not grandmas in a high-risk group
and we have
that's important it's important to say
that I actually think body language and
tone is important at any age to be
honest with you but let me ask you about
preteens go ahead yeah preteens I was
gonna say it's absolutely it's just
particularly important with younger
children you know live in a land of
magic don't really understand yet what's
going on now yeah kids are very little
let's go to preteen and teenagers right
so they're really a challenge them I've
gotten more calls about them than any
other group I think because they're just
at a stage where they're nothing matters
more than their friends and so if you
tell them they're not going out and they
can't see teenagers live in the moment
they're they like risk they like taking
risks it makes them feel good so I think
actually the calls that I've gotten at
the end of the day my advice is if your
kid absolutely won't listen to you you
got to bring the hammer down this is not
just about just about your kid I wanted
to ask you so we're running running out
of time here but quickly a lot of lot of
parents under tremendous financial
stress right now there's jobs lost there
there are questions about 401ks body
language and tone may be out the window
so how honest should people be with
their kids about what they're going
through you know I think the sense for
kids always has to be we've got this and
that's hard to do when you have no idea
whether you've got it or not
but I think you have to go back to your
own bucket of coping skills we all have
coping skills and you have to before you
get involved with your kids
pull up your coping skills you know I
just wrote this book that about an
uncertain world had been on your program
the week it came out last month and then
all hell breaks loose right and and I
think people were not prepared it we
certainly knew that there was going to
be some big time of uncertainty in this
country but we weren't prepared for this
particular one I think we have to make
sure that we're deep breathing and I
have a family the whole family deep
breathe before they go to sleep it
it helps I have to not be afraid to
discuss we have to be developmentally
appropriate we have to teach kids coping
skills and we have to give them a little
bit of control yeah very good advice
simple things are sometimes the most
effective Madeleine Levine thank you
very much